admit it you don't know the name of one  person on the US curling team but you do  know the name of negan's bat when the  games are over get back to what you love  The Walking Dead returns Sunday February  25th at 9:00 only on AMC admit it you  don't know what failing to land a triple  axel does to a score but you do know  what damage Darrel to do with a rocket  launcher when the games are over get  back to what you love The Walking Dead  returns Sunday February 25th at 9:00  only on AMC admit it you don't know the  difference between the super G in the  giant slalom but you do know the  difference between the sanctuary and  hilltop when the games are over get back  to what you love The Walking Dead  returns Sunday February 25th at 9:00  only on AMC  you